okay so April is what we're in right now
and it is financial literacy month and
it turns out here in Nevada we're kind
of falling behind yeah about 40 percent
of the teens that were surveyed here
they didn't pass the national financial
literacy test so let's talk about why
that's important and what you can do to
help your kids learn those skills even
if you're not so good yourself CEO of
busy kid certified financial planner
Greg mercet thank you so much for waking
up early to be here I'm here I love it I
love Vegas all right so let's just talk
pure into about why it's important for
kids at a young age to at least get the
idea of financial skills and financial
planning yeah money stuff is what
they're going to use the rest of their
life right they're going to make
decisions when it comes to money every
single day after you teach your kids not
to like steal and beat people up you got
to teach them about money okay like a
new golden rule this is it okay they're
going to use that every single day and
if they get good at it it totally
changes things for them but what if
you're not so good how do you do as I
say not as I do I like it so that's a
good question use technology okay I
think it's easier than ever to teach
your kids about money because of
Technology this is one of those things
that's made our lives quite a lot easier
okay and kids get Tech right they get it
you put an app in their hand and they're
all about it so give them the the
ability to start learning this stuff by
using technology I think it's
interesting because when we were kids
you know the financial literacy you
learned it would be you know it's papers
it's checkbooks old school stuff old
school I think when you make it
almost like a game as this with this
busy kid app it does help them learn and
maybe for parents too helps them learn
as well yeah it makes it kind of a Level
Playing Field right yeah so parents who
are not maybe not that great at like
stocks or understanding the market all
of a sudden we can start doing stuff
with 10 increments and learning together
and empowering the kid hey I'm going to
give you your own card so you can get
that I mean I'm going to keep track of
things I'm going to prove it but load
that card they can go make decisions on
their own and swipe the card understand
that stuff it really changes the game uh
Greg before we go we understand you have
some financial literacy questions you
have one that you can give us Grill us
if we know oh wow I know let's put him
on the spot here
um is the market up or down today well
we don't know we won't know for four
minutes
good job no it's so important and so
busy kid easy to easy to download is it
a free free app it's not free but it's
cheap it's only 48 a year for the whole
family so four bucks a month great um
and you can really Empower your family
to learn about money that's so important
learn financial literacy early it is so
vital Greg thanks for coming appreciate
the time thanks for the education and
duplication